fortnite battle royale has gone from a
world of mute characters to a place
where real-life celebrities can rock up
any time and hit one-liners straight out
of the movies i got over it today we are
looking at the actors behind the
characters we know and love starting
with everyone's favorite operative agent
jones they did it
we're still here jon jones first spoke
to us on the day midas turned on his
device we somehow teleported into his
office one day and overheard him talking
to a co-worker uh no everything is not
stable over here we are janice janice uh
dial the resonance actuator to 7.2 now
please yes right now agent jones then
became a huge part of the storyline so a
huge actor was needed to voice him which
so happens to be troy baker and i just
read through a bunch of stuff he's like
how much do you charge it's like how
much should i charge because this much
troy is one of the most renowned video
game voice actors in the business and
isn't afraid to put on a weird mocap
suit too mr baker plays joel in the last
of us turns out there's a whole lot more
like you really he's the joker in arkham
origins not so different
you might learn something about yourself
you need to learn to shut up he's reece
in borderlands ever since jack died the
loader bots have been getting smarter
and smarter and he's even the caped
crusader himself in the telltale series
the canister exploded sending shrapnel
right through the container door
at this point it feels like if you've
played a video game troy baker is
probably in it and to think fortnite
characters were still mumbling nonsense
without midas his device that day
fortnite travis scott
so let's talk about midas since he
arrived in chapter 2 season 2 this is
what he sounded like
charming sarcastic gibberish all voiced
by matthew mercer yeah what and okay
yet another behemoth in the voice acting
world he's best known for voicing
jiturokujo in the english dub of jojo's
bizarre adventure hi there my name is
matthew mercer i'm the voice of jotaro
cujo just take a damn seat he's also
spyro in skylanders yo snap out of it
and most people know matthew for his
role in overwatch
watch and learn
that character has been renamed recently
to cole cassidy and if you don't know
why i'm sure someone in the comments
will tell you
now coherent voices are a thing in
fortnite mercer has upgraded his random
noises into full sentences thanks to the
upcoming animated series about midas
shadow unit a story for weary soldiers
to frighten the fresh recruits
and of course i'll be breaking down
those stories when they arrive later in
2022 so click subscribe or don't you do
you staying with chapter 2 season 2
remember the battle pass trailer
welcome to the agency you come highly
recommended
that sexy british accent was voiced by
amy pemberton who is best known for her
role as gideon in dc's legends of
tomorrow the legends
they taught me humanity
you really believe that don't you
but here's the thing did you know that
amy also plays penny garbage
rats
severe structural damage this penny is
from save the world and right now she is
still mute in battle royale but i have
high hopes that one day she will speak
to us all
rats let's jump back up to date with dr
sloan yeah but the zero point is exposed
you have to go in we first heard sloan
via a telephone and then an earpiece
conversation but soon after her full
reveal began
all right listen up
we don't have much time sloane is voiced
by mara juno who has a very impressive
resume including shula in arcane
yeah that character doesn't say much
she's lisa ingention impact what's the
hurry
i thought we agreed to meet them here
and the one which made me say wow is her
voice as aikora ray in destiny 2.
[Music]
and if you're wondering mara has also
recorded gibberish speak for fortnite
when she's trapped a sloan inside the
loop oh yawning
right now for those masked weirdos we
call the seven and the scientist the
scientist has been played by two actors
in the past the first time we heard his
voice was via audio recordings but the
seven of us are attempting is
very risky we weren't 100 sure these
recordings were from the scientists and
i personally thought they were from the
visitor instead but luckily the mustard
we called donald confirmed it was the
scientist who gave us that monologue the
zero point must be contained once more
the og actor is jb blanc a man with
another mind-blowing back catalogue of
game credits jb is the voice of karstic
in apex legends but a character who's
the villain of the piece death is
inevitable
but has this steel cool calm your
gratitude is acknowledged he's kano in
model combat 11. i only need two strikes
to get you and he's another arcane actor
playing the legend that is vanda so i
guess we're all disappointed and he's
been on screen too playing dr barry
goodman in the breaking bad franchise
and my personal favorite is this jb is
rost in horizon zero dawn
[Music]
mr blanc is a busy dude when the
scientist was eventually brought back
into fortnite he was recast no longer
was he a brutally focused and serious
individual he became the joker of the
group
it's right up here and i will give you a
water break soon
the new actor is joel mchale a movie tv
and video game actor who is quite
prominent over in the states yes
absolutely that's exactly what i'm doing
i'm bragging most noticeably he played
jeff winger in community as well as tad
o'malley in the x-files do you miss it
at all
the x-files he's in spider-man 2
watching peter run away from doc [ __ ]
oh that boy yours is a real hero
you'll find joel voicing video game
characters most recently he appeared as
johnny cage in the battle of the realms
tv show
whoa
whoa
and now he's the voice of the scientist
that is our way in
hold them off
which do you prefer the ultra serious
and self-reflective scientist or the
goofball jokey guy i got my data and you
got your steps in win-win let's go back
to the marvel season chapter two season
four the season brought voice actors
from the marvel world and put them on
our island the first we heard of was
thor my memories are broken
but i know i brought these mighty
warriors here to defend our reality thor
is played by travis willingham and has
been playing the blonde bombshell
forever in video games and tv shows he
basically is thor these days i'm travis
willingham and i play thor he can be
also found voicing other marvel legends
including wilson fisk kingpin in the
spider-man playstation games get the
chopper ready
i won't be long
and cartoon reference he's cannon bolt
in ben 10.
okay i was impressed nobody else's along
with thor came other heroes including
tony stark the guy who really saved
reality from galactus you look like
someone who needs a jet pack
there you go
tony is played by arguably the greatest
video game voice actor ever nolan north
i am nolan north i play tony stark this
role came via another video game project
the avengers giving the character more
continuity nolan is in every video game
ever made or at least it feels like he
is he is nathan drake he is your ghost
in destiny he's desmond miles in
assassin's creed he's even on the jedi
council in star wars the old republic he
is mr video games oh and on tv he's also
blaze in blazing the monster machines
connect the hose to the water tank you
got it please yeah some other marvel
characters came to fortnite including
galactus himself remember what he said
i
hunger
galactus is played by geno siegers i can
get you to jenna
no sorry geno seekers a man with a voice
so silky it will make her mum slip off
her chair he was teaching me about
warm-up techniques cool down techniques
uh just for you know people with voices
like ours and grooty's here too can you
guess what line he has
yep you're right i am groot grooty's
played by adam harrington who continues
to play this character in many other
projects get it done as quickly as
possible you know be on time be
brilliant be gone
uh they're gonna call you back so he's
getting paid to say the same thing over
and over again now that is talent
indeed i wanted to talk about other
characters in save the world but it
seems that epic doesn't love that part
of fortnite anymore so we shall end with
the foundation yeah i know that you know
that that is the rock you promised me
geno
well
love you too but did you ever think
about other languages who plays spanish
rock
he's been dubbing the rocks rolls for
years including the fortnite reveal all
the way back in chapter two juan is a
bit of a hero in his own right too
voicing spanish versions of many
characters whether that's brian in
family guy or even thanos himself in
spanish marvel productions
important
there you go hopefully you learned
something new today i'm adam stick
around for more fortnite videos in
future and think about using code
adamaru like these legends here thank
you very much for using my code i'm
sorry i'm so far behind on my twitter
dms i will get back to you all right
it's been a pleasure i'll see you next
time muchachos
[Music]